assalamualaikum guys how are you doing
I'm heading get an early start here
visiting where the mass pikna is going
to be that's coming up at the end of
December
and what I really like about this will
tell the mccormick place
i tried to understand muslims better i
tried to understand they have questions
and they've invited me ethical so the
third or fourth year third year maybe
fourth harbour Loma convention in the
calling I mean come in to answer their
questions so tradition here I'm really
happy I hope other
chains tilted follow in their footsteps
[Music]
to what they're doing because they're
doing something wonderful here because
the Muslims are coming back
and holding the convention here so let's
go
right here at the Hyatt
Salam alaikum I'm here at the Hyatt
Regency in downtown the staff and
everyone here is preparing them up to go
up have a meeting with the staff and
this is a third year going on they've
got a great tradition going where they
invite me in kind of familiarize them
the staff has questions and their
interaction with Muslims and they want
to know they they want to know so they
can do a better job at serving the
community when they come in here so I'm
going to go in try to do my part and
share because you care you share so
we're sharing we're helping them
understand and clearing many other
misconceptions and delivering you know
the real purpose of what this message is
about what Muslims are about what we're
not about and being a voice for us
instead of others being voiced against
us so I'm going to go up in a few and
meet with them and I'm going to invite
you guys to attend if you're in the
Chicago area I'll be there and sha Allah
God willing to new tune and watching the
Deen show every week new show subscribe
like follow guys the mass Ignis coming
up and the staff here is doing an
amazing job we just had a wonderful
meeting coming up but you guys ready for
December what is it a 2026
see you soon hey hey all right make sure
you guys right here the staff is excited
to meet all you guys see a piece Tommy
repeat take two
[Music]
as uh so we got the massacre coming up
the staff is here they're excited to
meet up with you guys again
[Music]
excited to to familiarize them with
there's a lot of negative hype with
revolving around this anonymous people
know
I hate machine the hey provocateur is
really working working hard to create
confusion fear in the masses and this
this group here of
people at the Hyatt they've really
they're doing their best to make you
guys feel welcome really commended them
other hotel chains and other
disorganization
it's just bad for business hate is bad
for business small things from how we
greet each other how we pray that we
believe
to humanize people who are being
dehumanized mr. muscles I mean you see
so much of money is being spent reading
this fear trepidation in the heart but
when you make that connection when you
learn you grow so God will show along
what have you here the mass picnic
informants enter
[Applause]
make sure you guys attend
continue if you have if you're tuning in
if you have any questions if your hotel
chain
guys better catch up they're leaving you
behind you can hook up with us
call us